the winners of the 2017 Pulitzer Prizes
will be announced today at Columbia
University in New York photographer Carl
Busey is the only person to have
received four of the prestigious award
for journalism
she has travel a globe always seen light
during the darkest tragedies some of her
Pulitzer prize-winning photographs have
become iconic Jan prophet is at the
Museum in Washington DC where she spoke
to Guzzi Jan good morning good morning
Charlie you know Carol goosies
photographs are on display here at the
Newseum along with every other award
winning Pulitzer Prize photograph now
when she was growing up Guzzi says she
had no idea what a photojournalist was
she was looking for a stable career so
she studied to be a nurse but a friend
gave her a camera and she found her
calling when a Colombian volcano erupted
in 1985 and killed more than 20,000
Carol goosies images of the tragedy won
her and her Miami Herald colleague the
first Pulitzer Prize for spot news
photography nearly 10 years later US
troops entered the impoverished island
nation of Haiti goosies images for the
Washington Post again brought the
faraway conflict to people back home
earning her a second Pulitzer I don't
believe the pilasters belonged to us I
think we just accept them for the people
that are in her stories they're the
courageous ones and they're the ones
who've opened up their lives so that we
can take those pictures and tell their
stories to capture those powerful
moments Guzzi tries to connect with the
people that are photographs to imagine
their suffering you see things that
other people may not I definitely have
an overdose of empathy I think that's
probably the key word to make compelling
images in 1999 when tens of thousands of
ethnic Albanians fled violence in Kosovo
Guzzi traveled to the border capturing
images of hope and heartache that earned
her and her team a third Pulitzer but
the experience brought her to an
emotional breaking point I felt so
guilty that I'd be able to get on a
plane and leave a lot of these places
and the suffering state yeah the people
were stuck in that in their reality long
after the headlines were gone but I
think you learned to Co
I am realizing it is mission it's not
it's not just a job after leave of
absence Guzzi returned to the post and
again began traveling the world covering
humanitarian conflicts from India to
Ethiopia making France along the way a
photo story on child amputees from
Sierra Leone resulted in a number of
adoptions including a young girl named
mimouna who became goosies goddaughter
but again and again she returned to
Haiti
the country was ravaged by an earthquake
in 2010 it shook Guzzi to her core I
love the people and I love the spirit
and it was like my second home almost so
and when the earthquake happened that
just about destroyed me her coverage of
the recovery effort earned Guzzi and her
colleagues an historic fourth Pulitzer
goosies pictures now hang alongside
hundreds of other Pulitzer prize-winning
photographs at the Newseum a testament
to the power of images to change history
like kevin carter's 1993 picture of a
starving sudanese girl
William Beals 1957 picture of a
policeman talking with a young boy this
is only you know the tip of the iceberg
when you think of all the images that
have been made goosies photographs often
show hope even in the darkest of
circumstances it's what she searches for
when she arrives in a place like Haiti
like this this poor little girl and
three hundred thousand other people they
they were gone in a whisper or worse
buried under you know layers of concrete
and died days later weeks later even
when you see that how do you just keep
moving to take those photographs I tend
to always look for those moments of hope
too because I think we need balance we
need to show people not only the
problems but sometimes the solution too
and it saves my faith in humanity for
sure and in that way these photos can
affect change to a journalist like Guzzi
that's the real reward for me anyway
it's always been my life and and a
calling of sorts to you know to make
people aware and every now and then
things do change
she may be slowly and incrementally but
pictures can make a difference I think
now I ask you see where she displays all
those pilasters that she's won you know
is it in her office or on the mantel and
she said they're in a box somewhere I
mean she's not exactly sure where and I
just think that that shows for
journalists like Guzzi it's not the
awards or the recognition that matter
it's the people and the stories Alex
Shan think just goes to show the power
of the picture you know brings brings to
life the stories of people caught in the
worst ER and the question of what makes
a great photographer
sure is it the eye or empathise exudes
part of it